le moment c'est très simple à jamais
le python l'emblème le jeu emblématique
de tébessa de bachiri des cadeaux une
balle jouée par contre au moins des gens
pourront dès janvier quand vous gagnez
la balle vous partez vous choisissez le
cadeau que vous voulez garder vous
descendez du caméo n'ai plus jamais ça
va tu voudras montré dans un camion de
pharmaciens puissent convenir à votre
père me boileau permis connaître et à
mieux nous a dit diane et ses rues sales
est vraiment adapté à pic en gare
[Musique]
la montagne
bravo aux personnes
[Applaudissements]
enfin elle
à l'école il a valu j'allais rentrer la
bise 0 bien sûr mais tout ça m'a pris
beaucoup de galles je choisis le cadeau
que tu veux qu'ils s'y prenant bien des
déplacements à l'aide d'une maquette est
appelé pour la dca ce que tu veux le
projet du père photo sort allez c'est
bon c'est confirmé l'ons
[Applaudissements]
tel que je peux
je le promets je te laisse une deuxième
sous sol
ce sera presque champion
[Musique]
longtemps je donne quand même un petit
câlin salutations jallet michaud et a
fait beaucoup de personnes là qui
veulent c'est parti c'est le pic pomme
de la nuit
il est comme ça pour la paix
m je rappelle le principe était noir
vous partez avec un cadeau que vous
choisissez c'est vous perdez le point
bien entendu vous partez à karachi
calcutta vendus d'après bruno windows
merci j'ai la chance d'un emploi
livraison le raymond qu'elle avait comme
dirait mon attention renchérit un petit
oiseau va sortir ses parts avait des
trop gros pour sortir toi allez mon
chéri mon boulot de lévis très attention
on peut noter près mon chéri rapatrie
les shows tout ce que je dirai à savoir
inclus sinon moi aussi je vois rien et
la voie dégagée
j'ai caché la piste d'envol et docile
des champions
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est le programme le point
gagnant au giallo voilà je tenais là
petit cadeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre connectez vous connecter pour voir
si il faut y aller au delà c'est parti
salue les beautés naturelles et là à la
béa boucherit de sortie de sa voiture
vers la même temps qu il m arrive
aujourd'hui comment tu t'appelles et aux
fils et aux frais wafa mal
enlève ta magie du blessé qui peut bien
sûr bien sûr tu as compris le passé
passer du ping pong
[Applaudissements]
si tu gagnes tu choisis le canon que tu
veux
si tu perds sans permis c'est une balle
ah mais ça bouge est-ce que tu choisis
une balle ou de points gagnants l'un
tellement c'est bon le vol de points
gagnants et des points deux points c'est
vrai tu aimerais tu joues au labour
je m'étais pas aller 1 0 n'a accordé que
ces fainéants vers madère ils veulent
plus de toi al-aqsa me calme toi ça te
voilà par la lra fabre attention c'est
dans cet effort mais parce que ça dépend
de mon cher il est déjà sur les tartans
voiture qu'il était là n'est fait on
perd et on voit tirer la nouvelle tombe
en voiture vers les partis sont bien des
parents écoutent captait faire du tout
permet de gagner sept actuellement ça va
vous faire
[Musique]
je veux dire aveugle et schubert ce
petit bouffon
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti refah
bien moche et l es gens descendent des
voitures légères gelées centre des lois
sociales qu'attends tu ressors j'avais
voté récemment
non rappelons ces prêts pour un nazi le
point d nord c'était comme des mutuelles
championnat cbb championnat jean louis
jeune fille fait partie nhat hanh benson
ou les trous noirs ont atteint 12 en
tout genre 12 ans
renchérit m oui alors on y va c'est pas
humain avec concentre-toi n'est pas vrai
elle pas peur du tout près et nous faire
mal et a fait part de son souhait avec
la tête gagnant alla bout de chemin
cette façade ma mère assa a laissé
marquer
à la gare est pareil
c'est quand tu pars avec sa salle et
boucherit quoi nous servirait la parole
des facilités dans la série mercy
salut j'ai bien regardé pied
qui les a prises à ce qu'ils disent mais
pourquoi tu t'appelles dina dinah alors
sauvé kaboul a tué magnifique mais il a
des yeux magnifiques s'était vu tout à
l'heure les pilotages voulez vous c'est
dire ça y est les gens et c'est parti on
est un petit truc gens de la vel satis
amateurs ou non pour moi je restais au
connacht égide à bercy ont démarré chéri
est en tout cas à la crémade abattant je
vais trop de près mais toi aimer toi là
tu pourrais tout du temps là est
d'accord j'ai de la peine de vous gagnez
si tu crois que je vous laisse y gagner
à l'éthanol à l'évasion et c'est parti
lézina il avait dit au revoir à dinard
[Applaudissements]
quoi
ouais
non seulement cette fois c'est par à 102
points gagnants monsieur mais pour la
soirée attention je rappelle aux
facilités ou non gilardino jacques
annaud pourquoi mathieu c'est quoi
par contre la pauvreté italia bah ouais
il faut trouver quelqu'un qui est
[Applaudissements]
l'origine à la coalition sous php vous
déversez mais syrie ça va mais amour
pour l'instant comment eva joly ci avant
alors lui il croyait qu'avec le choix et
qu'il faut savourer un comptable du
travail thébaux la saison va tu
t'appelles mon chien c'est merci mais ça
va venir si tu joues un peu quoi non pas
du tout je fais quoi dans la vie trois
hommes qui inquiète donc y donner un
cadeau tournai tarnos jeunes est un
cadeau tout de suite alors on peut
peut-être s'arranger venu tableau des
points
on y va tous points la commande minutes
on attend que sa muse et inquiète toi
c'est beau de toujours principe c'est
parti mon chéri
c'est pas très oui c'est parti de là mon
cher à toi de cagliari 1 0
on verra
elle a fait partie un cadeau un cadeau
chopin sénat n'a pas bien
ouais smartphone tu vas te retrouver
l'enfant connectés oui l'amour la
solitude
cette partie cette forte qu à terme mon
chéri ça lui chante quant à nissan et
wallers heure suisse adopte un look tout
va jouer au tennis mais il a marché
c'est quoi alors elle a été près comment
tu t'appelles victor victor ouais tu
fais quoi dans la vie mon chéri fini mes
études là de quoi commerce à dieu ni
télé d'une forêt comme service terminé à
bientôt 40 ans d'histoire c'est pareil
dans un peu trop je suis venu et habite
à côté
enfin quand je suis né au courant pour
que la question devrait comme cadeau la
télé je ne veux la télé la mafia qui
veulent attirer vos choix vos deux
points gagnants de moyens tu choisis de
points gagnants après allez c'est parti
motion ya il échoue
ce à quoi le programme est lancé on s'en
va là l'impression la vase et bébé
j'attends padalino
bah ouais ouais mon chéri
où est la première du long pot non
[Musique]
voilà
prendre
la veste à col
[Musique]
je ne vois pas le lien avec vous
à les écouter
aussi tu nous fait mal à la tête ou la
scène et pourtant
[Applaudissements]
avantage pour les données grâce à la
télé vous regardez la volée et leurs
extraits de ses mots ni démocratie ni
s'approcher stade français je m'en fous
jamais quand tu veux chaussures et ses
volets alors sap autant plus qu elle
s'est installée à mes potes ce qui
suivra et dans l'un des meilleurs
restaurants callian je laime c'est
vraiment chez lui à toi ça
georges taifu bébé qui fait et lui alors
lui je me sens mieux à dire qu'ils
s'entraînent tous les jours je suis plus
ping pong aller faudra je commence très
tôt pour 4h à 6h où ça fait mal d'amour
pour les jo
on a trop chaud les trois jours c'est
une attente et s'est bien planté
cadeau coup
maintenant il attend portable au repos
pour ma femme comme ça le raisin à
culinaire est de me faire renoncer ça
mais c'est moi c'est moi qui cuisine
c'est moi qui cuisine numéro 4 e
le robot pour un jeu cuisine ses modèles
de robots aller j'avais eu quelques
ratés cette partie c'est le robot est
restée là aussi d'un champion mais
attention à la mecque je suis pas pour
rien si je veux pas qu'ils s'appellent
rapide que chez darty
allez-vous soit purgée
tout peut encore avoir un code oui jouer
deux ans à l'association du parti
le respect sur la bulle rassure
paul en batch et magnifique quand il a
tué très très bon bouche à moi chérie tu
as quel âge j'ai 13 ans à 13 ans c'est
parti on y va les prêts deux points tu
prends le cadeau que tu veux si tu veux
pas d'accord qu'est ce qui fait plaisir
l'obr bord way out of gaza
alors à ce qu'on peut faire c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
lol alors déjà pouces première fois je
donne le verdon c'est parti
j'ai quand même besoin de ton droit je
peux plus comme j'en ai l'air allez je
te laisse jeu phare match entre autres
est encore une autre de serre
allez sa diversité
il répond bien
[Applaudissements]
merci mais c'est un gars raison
d'efforts à vitré sa rage depuis cinq
ans à canalsat pour moi et je veux plus
le voir
merci tigre où tu peux l'être
ou pas je tiens tiens katia savent
assumer c'est parti katia une voiture
qu'est ce qui te fait plaisirs katia nom
partout en asie
allez c'est parti on en fait c'est pas
mal je fais
cette partie
selon l'antenne locale
qui est un cadeau pour tous
est-ce que tu le cadre d'un tour en
commun non connectés
g
oui event lui switch on a une chose se
fait là-bas remerciait les magasins but
respectivement face à paris pour une
caméra sous attention ma voix je me
coupe une contre attaque la revivre les
coutumes un swing suivre le festival
atteint 106,2 ne sai pa avec la chérie
que t'es pas elle faisait passer pour ce
papa de la crue de soutien appuyé de la
part de cubains
merci je voulais remercier les magasins
but sur cette opération
le faire dans tout va bien ou pas est
vrai qu'on tient un truc énorme
ce à quoi j'aspire à victoria avec du
petit ou double avec des mecs
le gros n'allait pas